you ask people to draw distinction to
describe
where are you acting and where are you
being
uh what's the difference what's uh
what's the difference between being fake
if I may use that word and being real
okay
yeah the word authentic gets thrown
around a lot and you know I I and
I don't mean
I used to think they used to feel this
way but but Bob Dylan loosened me up on
this idea a little bit what do you think
it's all about get to be there's your
only one and only true self
that's it everything else is fake
and then you hear Bob go well I mean we
are what we create ourselves be we are
our own Creations which I'm like ah yes
yes we are thank you Bob
Bobby
what
I'm all for
bullshitters and bullshitting
I'm not as big of a fan of
the liars and lying what's the
distinction you talking about the art
form of liars Liar's fake a Liars faking
it but not admitting to themselves that
yeah oh yeah it's [__] creation I'm
faking it yeah
um a liar I'm lying to your face right
now and I don't give you that hair of a
wink out of my right eye that lets you
know hey go with me here yeah I need the
value in the bullshitting yeah
now the lying becomes Troublesome
because one I've duped you and I didn't
let you know come on I was telling the
story about catching the fish the fish
always gets bigger every year we tell a
story come on go away all right yeah
but the lying all of a sudden
I don't know my own I don't know when
I'm emanating something and creating
something telling the truth being
authentic or lying and I'm
[__] all of a sudden I'm leaving crumbs
with myself a debt Constitution gets
blurry
lying to yourself and to others yeah
when you start to lie a lot of others
enough you start to lie to yourself you
don't even know it
and that I believe is dangerous
territory
that's why I'm trying to push this admit
because that goes I'm not I'm I'm trying
to come in at a kindergarten level
because we immediately jumped to
well I'm gonna judge that boom that's
bad that's wrong no no no no
hold back on that let's let's go back to
base level let's just admit
that we all [__] do it
Lies We Tell others Lies We Tell
ourselves Lies We Believe for
convenience sake I do it I'm guilty of
it I try to catch myself on it if I can
just call it and go you know you're
believing that lie out of convenience I
know and I even have to
I'm saying that in the mirror or writing
it down or sharing with a friend you
know and I go okay well now I've
inherently become a bullshitter then
because I admitted it
that I can shake hands with
that's the little slight wink to ourself
and someone else goes come on we're just
a better story this way and the chorus
road trip
you start with step one
admit
how do you do that how do you how do you
kind of step back and
do that inventory yeah
is there a trick to that
oh there's a trick to it I think it's
just about courage
of having them
because it's
I don't think any of us like to admit
our lives or look deep enough into go
I've relied so much on that lie that
it's become my reality
yeah and I'm and I and I I don't want to
be
so puritanical
as you say
again that's why I say to admit instead
of Judge
but I don't want to be so puritanical as
to go and admit it and get rid of it no
I'm just saying to admit it just bring
it to the surface
yeah I'm
saying this and I'm
doing something different
preached this but I actually my actions
just admit it
just just admit though just admit them
and
I think that's the first step to where
we
begin to
either forgive ourselves and give
ourselves some amnesty and go yeah I'm a
human trying to make it through life as
best I can I'm gonna let myself slide on
that one okay and maybe I've been
getting away with it for so long whole
family my whole network works well on it
okay
forget this get to the base of the truth
of the matter let me but just admit it
and then where will and then it will
also help it'll be easier to then expose
to ourselves which ones we go
no I'm not letting myself slide on that
anymore that is actually a lie I've been
believing that's been keeping me from
getting more of what I want in life
that's actually a lie I've been living
that I haven't admitted that
is not allowing me to enjoy life as much
as
I damn well should be
deserve to be or have earned to be or
just sort of let myself
excuse me and I had on it it's not all
the hard stuff sometimes it can be a a a
a fun thing I talk about how many times
do we major in our minors let's admit
where we sit there and we go
all right I give myself 12 hour work day
but I notice I'm spending eight on my
hobbies and four on my career
well I'm majoring in my minors
huh let me admit that there's the math
why don't we invert that I've had four
hours on my hobbies and eight on my
career
first off just admitting it allows me to
go well now I can do the math or
rearrange the math by time of day
but I I look I just found a hobby tennis
first topic I've had in 25 years
I had to admit that I that I went to
play tennis for this started to love it
for the first month
as I feel guilty
I was like I'm happy is it okay to have
this much fun I'm having so much fun and
I'm getting a great workout
I just admits I said yes it's okay
congratulations but you found something
that you're finding quite
pleasurable
for straight pleasure you don't have to
forget all this other stuff but yeah but
it's also getting a workout we're
getting that too but don't just you
don't have to excuse the pleasure based
on oh but it's it's good for you and
you're in it now you damn it the real
reason you love is because you you're
having so much damn fun at it I had to
admit that to let myself go damn right
I'm going to play tennis again today or
tomorrow it was a simple fun thing
so it's not always about the hardcore
stuff that we have to go
this is a deep dark lie that I've been
living by and it's having me live
falsely and it's having harmful
consequences on my loved ones
some of those will probably arise and we
admit
I think he's just having a look around
and just saying
and when we admit it
then we go when we admit a lie
then we become something much more
valuable
a bullshitter
yeah you had a little wink in your eye I
love the distinction I'm bullshitting
myself on that thing yep I'm lying
therefore if I call it a lime a minute
alarm yep well now yeah I'm bullshitting
eat now she's out didn't judge it
but now I'm [__] that I think we can
work with well you're an interesting
case study because you're one of the
most famous one of the most uh
charismatic successful
humans in the world there's a lot
millions of people love you hang on
every one of your words
that's a hard place to be
how do you call yourself how do you
admit
that you've been living a lie
how do you admit yourself in big ways
and small ways on lies at this point
given how many people love you how
famous you are
10 years ago I don't know
I I don't know someone was talking about
like
yeah they really admired this Stone to a
person because they're not someone who
looks in the mirror
and I was like yeah also I was like
man I gotta catch myself look in the
mirror a lot
and then I go in and I you know look at
my my wife's out of her bathroom
how many
favorite creams and stuff she has out
there look at my side I got a lot more
on my side I'm like oh
I noticed how if I'm out and public
working out maybe doing push-ups and
maybe I'd do a few more if
there's a group of people walking by
that maybe I'd like to impress that I
may do a few more than I do if I was on
my own I'm like
you were vain McConaughey
yeah and the knee jerk is oh vanity bad
but and also I was like
all of a sudden I became a bullshitter
once I admitted and then I was like well
Bravo vanity yeah let's go vanity
let's instead of putting it in the
cupboard
in the LIE section oh man I'm a vein
because I said that's a debit no
admit it
and then go what's the value in it well
look at me I actually got in better
shape because of my vanity actually I
eat better
better than that morning you know and
that led to being a better
better husband better dad
doing something with my kids when I'd
rather be over there writing this work
I'm working on but I know that
tomorrow
when they leave town they're gonna
remember this time that we had together
that's a selfish act to go spend that
time with my kids or my even though I'd
rather not be doing it at that time I'd
be doing something for myself
because when they leave tomorrow they've
got they'll have this great memory that
they spent with their dad right before
they went that that
I could call that vanity
I could group that
and say that's very vain of you that is
for self
yeah
because it
was also for something and someone that
I cared about other people in your life
that
I'll call you on your [__] in the
bad sense the Lord [__] yeah yeah
sometimes it's either I got a pretty
thick threshold for how far I can go
with my [__]
like what
bruise what tickles me might bruise
others to watch it
a good line
um tickles me my bruise others but I
also I go back and
talk about the [__]
that's over there with those mystical
successes
it's the yeah no no go with it
don't pull a parachute yet let's see how
far we can go let's see how hot I can
get let's try it one more time yes two
more please
that's
where a lot of great pleasure and
stories and successes will come from
those are mystical they don't add up
it's like we're not talking about reason
right now we're not talking logic just
go with this let's talk about the
virtual
and making it real the old line of fake
it till you make it I mean what is that
there's something to that
there's definitely something to it
but I would you know where people go
fake it as I would go back to Dylan's or
create it yeah recreate it create and
recreate it
you know until you till it becomes
till you make it
um so I'll have people call my [__]
and a lot of times you're right
I think
when I handled the most healthy way is I
admit yes
and
I'm aware
so and I'm going to keep going
so you're not like resisting you're
denying it oh I will I will and I have
to watch that where I'm like
no I'm not that's not what I'm doing and
now and and usually when it's coming
from people there they're going no you
are it took I want to bid it and then
that's where I'm telling a lie
and that'll come up get me later and
I'll go
I didn't see it I didn't see I was doing
that
I was
either unaware wouldn't let myself be
aware I was denying that I was doing
that
would you say that's ego has ego been
bad or good for you gosh I think it's
been think I'm so thankful for
ego
um
does it
get off the Bridle for me sometimes and
run loose and run places and where
it's
not of service to others and has it to
hurt loved ones and even strangers yes
um
but I I also
when my ego is really strong
it's
it's in sync
with starving it's in sync with
where I serve myself
also serves as others serves others it's
those two are part and parcel they're
they're they're they're they're
intertwined
and that's the capital E ego that I
think I think could hope we all need
more of and that's what I mean when I
talk about selfish that's to redefining
that the real true meaning of that is
not doing something for self at expense
of your neighbor or harming others it's
for personal profit and pleasure that
also is profit and pleasure for
a utilitarian sends more
of others
and there's a there's again back to the
Paradox that I think there's a place I
know there's a place I believe there's a
place where those are in sync and when
my ego's healthy
um
I'm able to
say I'm sorry sooner for a lie or a
misdemeanor or harm somebody I'm able to
be more empathetic
because I got the confidence yeah
to be so I'm able to be more humble
but still have my chin High I'm a hard
high and look in the eye and go
yep my bad bogey guilty
I shank that one out of bounds man
that's beautiful so ego can be
constructive not destructive